-I haven't had a chance to see
you after "Avengers" came out.
But it went on to make
like $2.9 billion.
-Yeah, it made a few bucks.
-Yeah, it did.
It's like the biggest grossing
movie in the history of film.
-Right, yeah.
-Not too shabby, buddy.
Congrats on that.
-Yeah, not too shabby.
I'll take it. I'll take it.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And everyone's probably already
asked you all these questions,
so I won't --
-Lay them on me.
What do you got?
-Well, I mean,
was it sentimental?
Did you -- Were you sad when you
had to do the end -- last scene?
And --
-Yeah, it was very emotional.
I mean, it's
surprisingly emotional.
These movies are
a huge part of your life.
And so, when they
come to an end,
it really -- It has an impact.
-Were you wearing, like,
dots on your face
or CGI, like, ping-pong balls
on your face?
-No, luckily, I don't
have to do that nonsense.
But it still -- It still --
You know, it still
had an effect.
-Well, yeah, I mean,
but you're doing the thing.
But in the movie when you see
it, I mean you have the --
I can't spoil it
at this point, right?
-No, no, yeah. This is so nice
'cause this is after --
-People have seen it.
-We can say anything we want.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But you're old.
-Yeah.
-They did such an amazing job
making you old.
Did that freak you out?
-They did a good job.
Well, they did -- They did --
A lot of it was prosthetic.
They left my mouth
without the prosthetic
so they could add that CGI.
I guess that's actually still --
still hard to do.
But they left my mouth the same,
but even just having the whole
face, you know, you kind of --
It's like looking
at your grandfather.
-Yeah.
-It's a strange feeling.
-Well, the good news is
you're a good-looking old man.
[ Laughter ]
You're going to age very well.
-That's what I heard,
yeah, yeah.
-Did Anthony Mackie --
I know all the scripts and all
the scenes are very secretive.
And did he know that you were
going to give him the shield?
-You know, there's actually
a really great story with that.
The secret -- The scripts
are so lock and key,
but they had given me the scene
where I pass the shield
to Mackie.
Oh, it's so nice
to be able to say that.
You know, it doesn't
have to be a secret.
-It's like therapy.
I want you to lay
down on the couch
and just talk about
the Marvel secrets, yeah.
-But -- But -- I did know that
Mackie was getting the shield,
and while we -- This is actually
a really nice story.
While we were filming
in Atlanta,
you know, I had already
read the scene.
I had a few people over to watch
a football game or something,
and Mackie was the first one
to show up.
I didn't know he didn't know
what was going to happen.
And he showed up first,
and I said,
"Hey, man, you know,
isn't that scene fantastic?"
And he said, "What scene?"
And I said, "The -- The scene
where I give you the shield."
And he said,
"You're giving me the shield?"
[ Laughter ]
And I said, "Oh, no. Oh, no."
Well, yeah." And so I ran
to my room, and I got the scene,
and I gave it to him, and I got
to watch him read the scene
for the first time
where he's getting the shield.
And he was so happy, and, you
know, you immediately feel like,
man, maybe I -- Maybe I robbed
this moment from --
Maybe Kevin Feige deserved this.
But it was so nice to share it
with him.
He was so happy and, you know,
so deserving, and it was just --
-It was a great moment.
-It was a nice way
to kind of have,
just between us,
the transition of characters.
It was great.
-I got to see it
in a theater full of people,
and one of the biggest
parts of the movie
that got a big reaction is
when you pick up Thor's hammer.
-Yeah.
-That was a big moment.
Yeah, I mean --
Everyone went nuts.
Like, "What?!
I knew he could do it!"
Like, yelling.
"I knew he always --"
Was that --
-I don't think
Hemsworth liked it.
[ Laughter ]
-"Hey, there's only one Thor,"
yeah.
What would feel better, picking
up the shield for the first time
or Thor's hammer
for the first time?
-Hammer.
-Really? [ Laughs ]
-Yeah. Well, you know,
the shield was destined
for the character.
The hammer was kind of this,
you know,
period at the end of a sentence
in terms of his worth,
and, yeah, it was nice.
And the Russos really know
how to build those moments up.
-They were great.
-I'll say the hammer.
-They did such a great job
with that.
Everyone just knocked it
out of the park.
Let's talk about your new film,
"Knives Out."
-Yeah.
-A totally different character
than Captain America.
-Yeah.
Well, we finished
the last scenes of "Endgame,"
and I went into "Knives Out"
only a week later.
So it really was a --
It was a real 180...
-Wow.
-...in terms of character.
-Can you explain what the movie
is about to everybody?
-I can try.
It's kind of a murder mystery
in the vein of Agatha Christie.
Everyone is vile.
Everyone is awful.
Everyone's a suspect.
But those are the movies I love.
You know, those -- Those are
the movies -- It's like "Clue."
-Yeah. Oh, yeah. Yeah.
-These are the movies --
-With a great cast.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Daniel Craig is in it.
Michael Shannon.
-So many -- Jamie Lee Curtis.
-Jamie Lee Curtis.
Don Johnson.
-Don Johnson.
-This guy -- I love that.
-Toni Collette?
Come on.
-Oh, Toni Collette.
I mean, you stop right there.
-She can do no wrong.
-Yeah, exactly.
-And that's just --
I mean, across the board,
everyone was --
-You don't know
who's telling the truth
and who's lying
the whole way through,
which is what you want
a good mystery to be like.
Are you a good liar
in real life?
-No, I'm a terrible liar,
which is so weird,
because I act for a living.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But, you know,
you when have lines
that you're supposed to say
in the context of filming,
it's great.
When it's actually real-life
lying, I feel like I --
I have every tell
you could possibly have.
I get red. I sweat.
My eyes gaze.
I'm touching my face.
[ Laughter ]
-You can't --
You don't have a poker face.
-I'm horrible at poker,
which is such a shame,
'cause I love the game,
but the second the cards
are dealt, I'm like --
[ Giggling ]
-"Ah, I got an ace!
Oh, no, I didn't."
[ Both babbling ]
Like, we can't play
with you anymore, dude.
-Out the gate. It'd be easier
if I just give you my money,
and I'm gonna go
have a drink at the bar.